Пані Оксано, колись ви називали Шевченківську премію радянським рудиментом,
який неможливо реформувати.
Ви зараз змінили свою думку?
Я би так відповіла на ваше запитання, що історія цієї премії,
вона певним чином десь відбиває мучену і тяжку історію становлення української державності.
Пост-УРСР, з усіма збереженими інституціями, тільки із нагородженням посмертно жертв тих,
хто в 70-ті і 80-ті був нагороджений за життя: "кат і жертва в одній ямі".
Моя думка і моє переконання, на якому я стою,
і моя умова, на якій я погодилася на цю номінацію,
бо згода на номінацію на відміну від Нобелівської премії, чи Букера, чи Анґелуса тут вимагається…
Моя умова була та, яку я і висувала, -
державна премії в галузі культури, мистецтва, музики чи літератури,
держава має її давати від свого імені за твори,
які мають державотворче, тобто політичне значення.
Я сказала - ніякої "художки", і це має бути тільки книжка моєї публіцистики.
Ось ця сама "Письменник на війні", ось ця сама "І знов я влізаю в танк",
книжка, яка для мене особисто була чистою жертвою.
Тобто я її розглядаю як свою ніби мобілізацію в цій війні.
Ви кажете про власну війну. В принципі, з назви цієї книжки воно випливає абсолютно очевидно.
Але багато людей, які брали участь у подіях 2014 року,
можливо, пізніше - у подіях російської агресії на Донбасі з українського боку,
хто не брав, але активно спостерігав за тими подіями, зараз кажуть, що вони розчаровані.
Що те, що відбулося, було марним. Ви розділяєте цю думку?
Я не думаю, що багато українців, які справді брали участь у цих подіях
і справді стали боронити свою країну, кажуть, що це було даремно.
Люди розуміють, над краєм якої прірви вони пройшли.
І люди цінують те, що вони зустріли цей рік у своєму Харкові, Запоріжжі, Миколаєві,
Одесі зі своєю родиною, без тривожного чемоданчика під ліжком.
Але для цього просто треба розуміти ту міру загрози, яка готувалася і якою ми були атаковані у 2014 році.
А ті, кому все було даремно, це - ті, хто не розумів тоді, що відбувається, так і сьогодні не розуміє.
Ці люди ніби поза фокусом історичних подій.
Такі завжди є впродовж цілої людської історії, але не вони цю історію творять.
Але ці люди, в будь-якому випадку, є виборцями.
Так, це проблема.
В 2010 році, коли Ви пояснювали під час презентації в Берліні "Музею покинутих секретів"
свій заклик голосувати проти всіх кандидатів у другому турі президентських виборів…
Проти обох.
Більше їх не було у другому турі.
Ви пояснювали це тим, що Янукович - це "невилікувана історична травма",
а Тимошенко - це умовний "гламурний авторитаризм", який не побачили українці.
Вона, як раз, ідеальна сурковщина. Путін в спідниці - це ідеальна сурковщина.
Але прихильники одного із кандидатів тоді казали, що "голосувати проти всіх" - це також технологія.
Зараз ви не передумали?
Обидва були технологією.
І Тимошенко, і Янукович - кожен із них був технологією.
Це були два різні сценарії. Це були дві різні башти Кремля.
Кремль і сьогодні свої яйця не в одну корзинку кладе, а розкладає їх по дуже різних.
Не проти всіх, я перепрошую.
Я дуже конкретно формулювала - я говорила "за Україну без Тимошенко і без Януковича".
Поки що ми на півдорозі. До речі, ніхто не цитує цього.
А я формулювала це саме так - "за Україну без Тимошенко і без Януковича".
Україна, слава Богу, вже без Януковича, але ще не без Тимошенко, на превеликий жаль.
Багато хто критикує і чинного президента.
І ось у березні фактично премію вам може вручати президент.
Ви не боїтеся, що таким чином, ненавмисно нехай, але
візьмете участь у його передвиборчій кампанії?
Ні, не боюся. Я не бачу нічого ганебного в тому,
щоби брати державну премію, раз ми уже
погодилися в тому, що вона така реформована
після 2015 року, із рук президента моєї країни,
котрий є одночасно головнокомандуючим армії,
котра всі ці п'ять років нівроку чинила опір, і котрий
немало зробив для того, щоби ця країна витримала,
устоялася і продовжувала боротьбу.
Тобто все-таки дав країні шанс.
Мені дуже не подобається, коли починаються всі ці,
знаєте, зараз розмахування, ці всі мемчики і
аватарчики типу "Порошенко - не мій президент".
Це навіть чисто з точки правової свідомості некоректно.
Ти громадянин - громадянин. Ти громадянин України?
Так. Якщо це не твій президент, то хто твій президент?
Путін? Тут дуже обмежений вибір, насправді.
Ви не боїтеся, що на кшталт ось цих європейських інтелектуалів,
які нещодавно написали листа на захист ЄС
перед виборами до Європарламенту,
українським інтелектуалам - вам і вашим колегам, -
доведеться писати лист на захист євроінтеграційних прагнень для українців?
Давайте трошки змінимо оптику і усвідомимо собі,
що Україна сьогодні - на передньому краї
дуже великих і серйозних тектонічних змін,
що криза
сьогодні глобальна
і загальноцивілізаційна.
Криза, яка триватиме ну, принаймні, найближче десятиліття
і на виході з цього десятиліття
не тільки мапа Європи, а й мапа світу може виглядати інакше.
І напевно виглядатиме інакше.
І в цих умовах ось цей наш кораблик…
Цей наш кораблик утримати, провести
через всі ці забурення
світової і європейської історії,
в якій ми були,
в якій ми були присутніми, забули про свою присутність і Європа забула про нашу присутність.
Для мене дуже показовою була тут лінія
союзників України,
яка в 2014 році вибудувалася тоді, коли
колишні імперії -
Німеччина і Франція, - ще демонстрували глибоку стурбованість
і, давайте називати речі своїми іменами, готові були
нормально здати, злити Україну в сферу державних інтересів Росії так,
як свого часу, в 1939 році, злили Польщу
у сферу державних інтересів Німеччини,
і ці мапи ми всі пам'ятаємо.
А тут раптом намалювалися дуже несподівані союзники
від Швеції до…
Швеція, країни Балтії, несподівано Румунія,
яку, здавалось би, пропозиція Путіна до Угорщини,
до Румунії і до Польщі взяти собі по шматку України,
вона викликала тільки у Орбана схвальну реакцію
і готовність собі негайно затерти ручки і собі взяти Закарпаття.
А Румунія, навпаки, замість того, аби приєднатися
до путінського антиукраїнського фронту, почала
вибудовувати зовсім інший фронт і переозброюватися.
Пані Оксано, буквально одним реченням... Я розумію, що це неможливо, але тим не менше...
Судячи з того, що ви говорите, це значить, що
шлях України до Європи спинити неможливо,
бо йдеться про якісь, як ви кажете, тектонічні зсуви?
Безперечно. Це наш шлях до самих себе.
І воюємо ми насправді не за те, щоб кудись іти,
а за те, щоб бути собою,
щоби реалізувати себе в історії
як повноцінна модерна нація. Нарешті.
Дякую вам, пані Оксано.
Прошу дуже. Моя приємність, як кажуть поляки.